pour steven dimitri alexis et clément le
déclic c'est l'école de production
[Musique]
leur avenir ils le voyaient plutôt floue
et puis c'est devenu net et précis
[Musique]
donc vous l'avez découvert dans le
bâtiment vous avez une deuxième salle de
cours la salle de pause qui est juste là
bien bonjour à tous donc c'est pour moi
un vif plaisir de vous accueillir dans
cette école vous allez découvrir dans
cette école je pense pour ceux qui n'en
sont pas très conscience que ça veut
dire respect et confiance
on a beau être en plein mois de février
c'est jour de rentrée scolaire pour
clément avec cinq autres jeunes il
n'avait aucune solution de formation
jusqu'à ce qu'il passe un entretien pour
entrer dans cette école de production de
besançon et vous avez la chance de vous
lancer dans une formation qui mène à
l'emploi toutes les écoles de production
qui existe en france les jeunes
lorsqu'ils sortent lorsqu'ils ont leur
diplôme deux trois mois quatre mois
après ils ont un job cette rentrée
décalée et pragmatique
il s'agit de ne pas attendre septembre
pour commencer à se former concrètement
c'est aussi répondre aux besoins de
l'industrie
la franche-comté manque de tourneur
fraiseur outilleur régleur opérateurs de
commande numérique
qu'est ce que toi tu souhaiterais faire
de quatre ans rester ici jusqu'à la fin
n'ont jusqu'à l'ag web et trouver du
travail ensuite en france vraiment
s'améliorer encore un peu affectionner
voilà d'accord et après partir en suisse
la suisse
c'est une possibilité mais il ya
peut-être d'autres choses en proximité
qui vous correspondent plus il n'ya pas
que l'argent pour l'instant vous riez
c'est normal mais vous verrez que ceux
de voir qu'au fur et à mesure et prendre
les enfants voyant ce qu'on peut faire
et prenez plaisir aux évents couple on
peut faire plein de choses différentes
josé gène there est l'un des trois
formateurs de l'école et il sait de quoi
il parle quand j'étais jeune j'étais à
grand décrocheurs scolaires
j'ai été viré de la quatrième c'est pas
parce que on était un jour à décrocheurs
scolaires qu'on peut pas aller plus loin
j'ai passé mon bac à 38 ans ça prouve
qu'on peut on peut se remettre en
question tout le temps mais c'est mieux
de faire quand on est jeune moi j'ai
perdu un certain temps et c'est pour ça
je me trouve maintenant entre deux
formateurs et ça me plaît j'ai envie de
transmettre
j'ai envie de transmettre à des jeunes
tu l'auras coup j'ai toujours écouté
tu as doit pas rentrer le dos rentrée
ici les jeunes passent deux tiers de
leur temps à l'atelier et ce qui est
produit et vendu la particularité les
écoles de production c'est que les
jeunes travaillent pour de vrais clients
et c'est la production pour ses vrais
clients qui nous amène un financement
maintenant effectivement le principe pas
exceptionnel nous permet de récupérer
des jeunes pour qui le système
d'éducation classiques ne fonctionnent
pas des jeunes qui ont envie très tôt
d'être dans le côté pratique des choses
et non pas dans la théorie qu'on peut
avoir quand on est devant un tableau et
c'est l'école est gratuite pour les
élèves le conseil régional et des
fondations complète le financement lui
et même le syndicat de la métallurgie
est un allié précieux
l'école production besançon a été porté
à l'origine par lui mm franche comté et
du coup on bénéficie de
du relais de l'ensemble des adhérents
humaine franche comté pour nous confier
dans un geste solidaire de leur
production de leurs ateliers former leur
opérateur de demander jeudi aura tout du
sol chocun d'orvault à une machine
clément veut devenir un de ces
opérateurs de demain avant cette rentrée
il avait déjà testé ces machines et
maintenant il est impatient de commencer
sorte c'est mon truc je pense que toutes
les machines travailler comme ça c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut avoir envie
puis j'ai envie donc
l'envi c'est aussi ce qui motive alexis
en juin il passera son ca paix et il ne
compte pas s'arrêter là